donc d'entre elles qui permettent de
décliner de manière opérationnelle les
différentes dispositions qui sont
prévues par la loi d'urgence je vais
donc céder la parole au premier ministre
pour vous présenter ses différentes
ordonnances ainsi qu'à différents
ministres de manière thématique je vous
remercie
mesdames et messieurs ce matin le
conseil des ministres a adopté 25
ordonnance sur la base des habilitations
qui avaient été consentis par le
parlement ce week end le nombre 25
ordonnance dans un homme conseil des
ministres est historique il faut
remonter à 1958 pour trouver un
précédent équivalent
c'est bien le signe que l'urgence dicte
sa loi jeudi et vendredi derniers samedi
puis dimanche le sénat puis l'assemblée
nationale ont voté dans des délais
exceptionnel dont je les remercie la loi
d'urgence pour faire face à l'épidémie
de kovy de 19 grâce à cet ensemble des
ordonnances qui ont été prise sur le
fondement de cette loi notre pays est
aujourd'hui juridiquement armée pour
organiser l'état d'urgence sanitaire que
la situation un peu l'objectif de ce
régime provisoire
c'est de protéger au mieux nos
concitoyens à commencer par nos
soignants qui se battent en première
ligne et je ne veux pas me contenter de
rendre hommage à leur courage
j'entends leur demande les assure
qu'elles sont absolument prioritaire
qu'il s'agisse des équipements de
protection d'abord des moyens de
transport des malades de l'hébergement
temporaire ou des financements c'est la
priorité des priorités du gouvernement
le second objectif de ce régime
d'urgence et de limiter autant que faire
se peut les graves dommages économiques
et sociaux que provoque inévitablement
le confinement premier point c'est le
soutien aux entreprises une première
série d'ordonnancés comporte des mesures
de solidarité exceptionnel pour
maintenir à flot les petites entreprises
les plus vulnérables
il s'agit de soutenir leur trésorerie
afin d'éviter des faillites afin
d'éviter des licenciements
ces ordonnances porte sur la création du
fonds de solidarité doté d'un milliard
d'euros dont 250 millions d'euros
provenance des régions il s'adressera
aux très petites entreprises aux micro
entreprises et aux indépendants les plus
touchés par l'épidémie
le report du paiement des loyers les
factures d'eau de gaz et d'électricité
la prorogation des délais légaux
l'adaptation des règles concernant les
marchés publics l'obligation des
contrats de vente de voyages et les
jours la protection des réseaux de
télécommunications fortement sollicités
dans cette période de confinement dans
tous ces domaines parfois très concret
nous apportons des solutions juridiques
qui vont permettre aux acteurs
économiques d'affronter cette période
dans de meilleures conditions
le deuxième point c'est la protection
des plus vulnérables
nous prolongeons l'éligibilité aux
minima sociaux pendant la période de
crise sans réexamen de conditions ceci
concerne le revenu de solidarité active
le rsa la complémentaire santé solidaire
l'allocation aux adultes handicapés
l'allocation d'éducation de l'enfant
handicapé
là encore il s'agit de faire en sorte
que les droits soient préservés et
poursuivie pendant toute la période de
confinement c'est la même logique qui
nous aide qui nous anime
s'agissant des droits des demandeurs
d'emploi qui viendrait à expiration
ils vont être prolongées le temps de
l'état d'urgence dans le même esprit
attributions du complément employeur est
assouplie pour les arrêts de travail
la trêve hivernale est prolongé jusqu'au
31 mai 2020 ainsi que la période durant
laquelle les fournisseurs d'électricité
de chaleur de gaz peuvent procéder à une
interruption des contrats enfin nous
assouplissons les conditions de garde
d'enfant chez des assistantes
maternelles pour accroître les capacités
d'accueil troisième axe le droit du
travail il est aménagé temporairement
pour permettre l'organisation d'une
véritable économie de guerre dans les
secteurs vitaux et sous conditions les
entreprises pourront des rondes et roger
et là encore je le répète temporairement
et avec des compensations ultérieure
au durée maximale du travail en règle de
repos hebdomadaire et dominical de même
des dispositions spécifiques permettent
d'aménager les congés payés les jours
octroyés dans le cadre de la réduction
du temps de travail
la ministre du travail aura l'occasion
de préciser ces dispositifs
enfin nous organisons bon fonctionnement
des services publics
nous prenons des mesures exceptionnelles
en faveur des établissements de santé
des établissements et services sociaux
et médico sociaux en apportant des
garanties sur les montants octroyés par
l'assurance maladie aux différents
établissements de santé il se trouve que
ces établissements de santé ont parfois
des programmes et des opérations vont
parfois leur fonctionnement financier
heurté par le l'épidémie et le
confinement il s'agit là encore de leur
donner toutes les garanties nécessaires
pour qu'ils puissent poursuivre leurs
activités dans de bonnes conditions
mais nous allons aider à la continuité
de l'accompagnement et la protection des
personnes accueillies y compris à
domicile pour la justice fera préserver
les droits et la sécurité de nos
concitoyens et concentrer l'activité
judiciaire sur les cas les plus graves
et aménager les procédures aux règles
particulières du confinement dans un
registre très différent diverses mesures
vous permettre d'organiser la continuité
des paiements de l'état et des
collectivités territoriales
le premier train de relance de ses 25
ordonnance qui sont prises aujourd'hui
est présenté en conseil des ministres
aujourd'hui il sera complété dans les
prochains jours c'est dans les prochains
jours que l'état sur à la prise en
charge totale des indemnisations versées
aux salariés par les entreprises en cas
d'activité partielle dans la limite de 4
5 e fois le smic et pour ne pas
pénaliser les entreprises un délai de 30
jours leur sera accordé pour déposer
leur demande avec effet rétroactif là
encore la ministre du travail viendra
expliquer ce dispositif est essentielle
pour permettre aux entreprises de passer
un cap
redoutablement difficile une ordonnance
viendra compléter je les dis dans les
tout prochains jours ce dispositif en
améliorant l'indemnisation des salariés
à temps partiel et celle des apprentis
et en l'ouvrant aux particuliers
employeurs
il ya là encore quelque chose
d'important avant de laisser les
ministres présentés en détail les
ordonnances adoptées dans l'eure
respectifs je voudrais souligner les
moyens exceptionnels qu'elle dégage ces
ordonnances pour faire face à la
brutalité du choc que subit le pays
c'est évidemment est d'abord un choc
sanitaires et c'est l'urgence sanitaire
qui anime tous les esprits aujourd'hui
mais c'est aussi et ce sera de plus en
plus un choc économique
un choc social nous ne sommes qu'au
début de la crise et le président de la
république a demandé à nouveau
aujourd'hui au gouvernement de prendre
tous les moyens nécessaires dans la
durée je le dis donc simplement aux
français c'est un effort long que nous
nous préparons et auquel nous allons
tous ensemble faire face je vous
remercie les ai passé la parole à madame
la garde des sceaux
bonjour mesdames et messieurs donc je
vais vous présenter quatre ordonnances
qui sont intervenus dans domaine
juridique et juridictionnelles notre
idée est de répondre à plusieurs défis
d'abord le respect des consignes lié à
l'urgence sanitaire qui s'imposent pour
les tribunaux pour le public que nous
recevons pour les établissements
pénitentiaires
la sécurité juridique de nos concitoyens
comme l'a dit monsieur le premier
ministre avec évidemment la volonté que
aussi bien nos concitoyens que les
entreprises évitent de pâtir de la
difficulté à réaliser certaines
démarches durant cette période
l'impossibilité de traiter les
contentieux courant mais la nécessité de
traiter les contentieux urgent et puis
évidemment l'exigence de respecter les
garanties essentielles qui fondent notre
système judiciaire
quatre ordonnances donc les deux
premières ordonnances s'attache à la
question des procédures et de la
prolongation des délais pendant la
période de l'épidémie nous allons à
cette fin permettre de
reporter les délais qui expire durant
cette période de crise sanitaire à la
fois pour que les bénéficiaires de ces
délais puisse continuer à en bénéficier
en même temps pour ne pas créer du fait
d' aubaine donc un délai supplémentaire
sera octroyée pour réaliser les
démarches qui devait normalement être
réalisé dans cette période
ça se traduit par la définition d'une
zone de protection juridique qui va
commencer le 12 mars et qui va s'achever
un mois après la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
un mois pour nous permettre de revenir à
des conditions de fonctionnement normal
toutes les démarches qui devait être
accompli pendant cette période de
protection juridique pourront encore
l'être au plus tard dans les deux mois
qui suivent cette période de protection
juridique donc 12 mars fin de l'état de
sanitaires un mois après puis deux mois
encore pour pouvoir accomplir ses
démarches ça ne veut pas dire évidemment
que toutes les obligations sont
suspendus durant cette période ça veut
simplement dire que nous ne pourra pas
être sanctionné si on effectue ses
obligations dans le délai supplémentaire
que j'ai mentionnés nous allons
également
c'est une autre idée prolongée de plein
droit certaines mesures qui se termine
pendant cette période d'état d'urgence
sanitaire et ce afin d'éviter un vide
juridique
je pense par exemple aux mesures de
tutelle d'assistance éducative ou bien
aux ordonnances de protection dont
bénéficient les femmes qui ont fait
l'objet de violences conjugales toutes
ces mesures sont prolongées c'est la
première ordonnance deux autres
ordonnances sur lequel je serai plus
brèves concerne le fonctionnement des
juridictions civiles et administratives
il s'agit de répondre aux impératifs de
la vie économique et sociale qui ne sont
pas différents bhl et donc il nous faut
tenir certains procès sans audience
basée sur la seule échange d écriture
des parties il nous faut permettre les
échanges entre ces partis qui pourront
se faire soit par visioconférence soit
par téléphone il nous faut permettre de
tenir des débats par tous moyens et donc
de la manière dont je viens de
l'indiquer
ces ordonnances dans également à adapter
les conditions dans lesquelles les juges
des enfants pourront continuer à statuer
au mieux pour exercer leurs missions
la dernière ordonnance concerne la
procédure pénale dans ce cadre là nous
avons d'une part pris un certain nombre
de décisions pour maintenir une activité
pénale dans des conditions qui ne porte
pas atteinte aux l'écho exigences de
l'état de droit par exemple
ces ordonnances et tendent les délais
d'instruction et de jugement notamment
les délais légaux de détention sans
préjudice des possibilités de remise en
liberté qui pourrait être demandée soit
à l'initiative des juges soient à
l'initiative des partis nous permettons
également aux juridictions de statuer
alors même que de nombreux magistrats
des personnels de greffe sont touchés
par le confinement et que les mesures
sanitaires interdisent le rassemblement
des personnes c'est ainsi que nous
élargissons les possibilités de statuer
à juge unique ou par visioconférence
enfin cette ordonnance pénale nous donne
la possibilité d'agir sur la tension
carcéral vous savez qu'un certain nombre
de nos maisons d'arrêt font l'objet
d'une surpopulation carcérale et que
évidemment cela peut poser des problèmes
notamment sanitaires
des mesures ont été prises pour éviter
ces difficultés sanitaires des mesures
ont été prises à la fois de suspension
d'un certain nombre d'activités ou de
parloir en détention compensée par des
mesures liées notamment la gratuité du
téléphone de la télévision est également
à des mesures dead ce dont je parle là
ne nécessite pas de mesures législatives
ou réglementaires cela ne fait pas
l'objet des ordonnances que je vous
présente en revanche
d'autres dispositions font partie d or
des noms dans ce que je vous présente
pour diminuer la tension carcéral nous
agissons à la fois sur les personnes qui
pourraient entrer en détention et sur
celles qui sortent pour les personnes
qui pourraient entrer en détention j'ai
demandé notamment aux parquets de
reporter la mise à exécution de peine
d'emprisonnement de personnes qui
seraient condamnés mais libre et qui ne
présentent pas de danger immédiat pour
les personnes j'ai également demandé
dans un contexte de capacité
d'investigation réduite de n'envisager
le placement en détention provisoire que
pour des personnes qui présenteraient
une réelle dangerosité pour les sortants
de détention nous avons pris des
directives générales qui permettent
d'apprécier peut-être avec davantage de
mansuétude qu'est l'accoutumée les
demandes de réductions de peine ou de
libération conditionnelle c'est ce que
font les juges d'application des peines
mais au delà l'ordonance prévoit la
simplification des dispositifs existants
ou bien des dispositifs nouveaux la
elle concerne l'examen des suspensions
peine délibérations sous contrainte et
bien les juges d'application des peines
pourront se prononcent prononcer plus
facilement notamment avec la tenue de
commission d'application des peines
dématérialiser voire même sans
lorsque l'accord du procureur existants
la création de dispositifs spécifiques
pour terminer il y en a trois le premier
dispositif prévoit la remise en liberté
des personnes détenues dont le reliquat
de peine est inférieure à deux mois et
qui seront alors placés en confinement à
leur domicile
deuxième dispositif prévoit des
aménagements de peine pour des personnes
dont le reliquat de peine est inférieure
à six mois et qui pourront alors faire
le
j'ai d'un travail d'intérêt général le
troisième dispositif prévoit l'octroi de
remise de peine spéciale d'un maximum de
deux mois pour les personnes qui auront
eu un comportement exemplaire pendant la
période d'état d'urgence sanitaire
toutes ces mesures évidemment ne
concerneront pas ni les terroristes ni
les criminels ni les personnes qui
auront été condamnées pour des violences
intrafamiliales
nous estimons qu'entre 5 et 6000
personnes devraient pouvoir bénéficier
de ce dispositif
l'ensemble des mesures que je viens de
vous présenter me semble-t-il établit un
équilibre entre à la fois la nécessité
de prolonger le service public par des
dispositifs simplifiée mais en même
temps de garantir le maintien des règles
essentielles à l'état de droit
bonjour à tous comme le premier ministre
vient de l'indiquer
la france fait face un choc économique
violent face à ce choc économique de
violent nous avons pris la semaine
dernière avec le président de la
république
deux dispositions majeures d'une part un
plan d'urgence économique de 45
milliards d'euros avec des mesures de
report de charges sociales et fiscales
qui pourront le cas échéant devenir des
annulations de charges sociales que
fiscales et des dispositifs de chômage
partiel qui ont été présentées par la
ministre du travail mme muriel pénicaud
et qui feront aujourd'hui de ce
dispositif de chômage partiel le
dispositif le plus généreux est le plus
efficace en europe
nous avons également mis en place une
garantie d'état de 300 milliards d'euros
pour l'ensemble des nouveaux prêts qui
seraient accordées aux entreprises
cette garantie d'état de 300 milliards
d'euros est disponible pour toutes les
entreprises à compter de ce matin toutes
les entreprises pour un chiffre
d'affaires inférieur à 1 25 milliard
d'euros et qui ont moins de 5000
salariés peuvent se présenter dans leurs
succursales bancaires habituels et
demandé à bénéficier de cette garantie
d'état
jauron un numéro d'enregistrement qui
sera fournie par la banque publique
d'investissement et ensuite elles
pourront avoir accès à cette garantie de
l'état sur leurs nouveaux prêts pour
toutes les entreprises qui ont un
chiffre d'affaires supérieur à 25
milliards d'euros et plus de 5000
salariés c'est le mini de l'économie et
des finances lui-même qui signera
l'arrêté portant garantie de l'état sur
les nouveaux prêts qu'ils pourraient
demander au delà de ces deux dispositifs
massifs qui ont été adoptées la semaine
dernière et qui sont maintenant en
vigueur le conseil des ministres a
adopté ce matin six nouvelles
ordonnances qui constitue une deuxième
vague de réponse massive à ce choc
économique
une première ordonnance modifie les
obligations des professionnels du
tourisme et pour alléger la trésorerie
des voyagistes leur permet de rambo
et les voyages qui sont annulés non plus
en cash mais sous forme de record de la
prestation ou de bons d'achat la
deuxième ordonnance porte sur les
factures d'eau de gaz et d'électricité
et aux paiements des loyers sur la base
du principe qui a été fixé par le
président de la république 0,7 pour un
certain nombre d'indépendants et de
commerçants donc en face 0 dépenses et
nous tenons à ce que ce principe
géraud recettes dont 0 dépenses soit
appliquée partout sur le territoire pour
tous les commerçants artisans
indépendants qui traverse des moments
particulièrement difficiles
c'est en donnant ce interdit donc la
suspension l'interruption et la
réduction de la fourniture d'électricité
de gaz et d'eau pour les petites
entreprises que je viens de citer
elle prévoit à la possibilité
d'échelonner dans le temps le paiement
de ses factures correspondantes sans
aucune pénalité et elle prévoit
également la possibilité de demander le
report ou la suspension du paiement des
loyers sur la base de l'accord que nous
avons trouvé avec l'ensemble des
bailleurs la troisième ordonnance
prévoit la mise en place d'un fonds de
solidarité se font dessus heydari t il à
destination de toutes les entreprises de
moins de 1 million d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires nous avons décidé de
l'élargir également aux professions
libérales
il doit constituer la réponse ultime à
tous ceux qui ne peuvent pas bénéficier
des autres dispositifs que nous avons
mis en place il s'agisse des reports de
charges sociales et fiscales des
dispositifs de chômage partiel
chacun doit avoir à signer de sécurité
dans cette crise et le fonds de
solidarité constitue ce filet de
sécurité pour tous les petits
entrepreneurs les très petites
entreprises
les micro entrepreneurs les indépendants
ou les professions libérales
toutes ces entreprises pourront donc
bénéficier de ce fonds de solidarité qui
va fonctionner à deux étages à premier
étage c'est une indemnisation
forfaitaire
2500 euros cette indemnisation est
automatique et j'appelle tous ceux qui
rentrent dans le champ de ce fonds de
solidarité je le rappelle tous les
entrepreneurs qui ont moins d'un million
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires qu'il soit
micro entrepreneurs indépendants
artisans professions libérales très
petites entreprises a sollicité le
versement de ses 1500 euros auprès de la
direction générale des finances
publiques
ils pourront en bénéficier dès la fin du
mois de mars tout début du mois d'avril
ce versement est automatique il repose
sur un principe de confiance et sur un
principe déclaratif
donc je le redis j'invite tous ceux qui
sont bénéficiaires de ce fonds à se
manifester auprès de la direction
générale des finances publiques
ils recevront automatiquement cette
somme forfaitaire de 1500 euros pour
tous ceux qui auraient besoin d'un
complément et pour lesquels les 1500
euros pourrait ne pas suffire
il y à a deuxième étage qui pourra aller
jusqu'à 2000 euros qui s'ajoutent à ces
1500 euros pour éviter les faillites des
plus petites entreprises
ce deuxième étage se fera sur
instruction des dossiers et les dossiers
seront instruits au niveau régional qui
nous paraît le plus pertinent pour
traiter de ces dossiers
je voudrais profiter de cette
intervention pour remercier les régions
qui ont accepté de contribuer à hauteur
de 250 millions d'euros à ce fonds de
solidarité et remercié également la
fédération des assureurs qui a accepté
de contribuer à hauteur de 200 millions
d'euros pour ce fonds de solidarité
le coût de ce fonds sera de l'ordre de 1
milliard d'euros par mois
il sera évidemment maintenue tant que la
crise durera nous ne laisserons personne
de côté
et chacun doit trouver une réponse à la
situation difficile que traverse
aujourd'hui le pays
une quatrième ordonnance porte sur la
possibilité de reporter l'application
des marchés publics et l'exécution des
marchés publics sans aucune pénalité
il prévoit également la mise en place de
règles dérogatoires s'agissant du
paiement des avances avec la possibilité
de payer des avances au delà du plafond
de 60% qui est fixé d'ordinaire ça
permet évidemment
d'alimenter la trésorerie des
entreprises en particulier du bâtiment
et des travaux publics
il n'y a donc plus de limite à ce
paiement des avances et au plafonnement
de ce paiement des avances la cinquième
ordonnance porte sur les assemblées
générales des entreprises avec la
possibilité de dématérialiser ses
assemblées générales pour éviter les
rassemblements de personnes voire de les
reporter en septembre si certaines
entreprises préfèrent les reporté de
quelques mois
enfin la dernière ordonnance prévoit
d'adapter les délais et les procédures
applicables renforcement des lignes
électroniques de communication
électronique chacun sait bien que les
réseaux sont extraordinairement
sollicité actuellement il peut y avait
besoin ici ou là dans le territoire de
renforcer les réseaux électroniques cela
pourra se faire en dérogation des règles
applicables normalement à cette
adaptation des communications
électroniques
donc vous voyez c'est tout un train
d'ordonnancé très pratique très
opérationnelle qui vise une seule chose
soutenir notre économie soutenir nos
entrepreneurs dans la période
particulièrement difficile qui traverse
actuellement
nous faisons face à une crise sanitaire
qui est inédite soit précédente
mais du coup également un choc
économique et social important par son
ampleur par sa nature et à mon tour je
voudrais saluer l'engagement
exceptionnel de nos administrations des
parlementaires qui ont quelques jours un
temps record ont permis d'élaborer et de
voter des mesures très importantes pour
sauvegarder les entreprises éviter les
défaillances d'entreprises protégé du
chômage les salariés et prendre en
charge les plus vulnérables ce matin
nous avons dans le champ du travail
l'emploi adopté trois ordonnances
s'inscrivent dans l'ensemble des mesures
prises en raison de la loi d'urgence
sanitaire
la première le premier objectif c'est de
permettre aux entreprises de ne pas
mettre la clé sous la porte d'éviter la
défaillance de ne pas licencier leur
personnel et donc de conserver les
compétences pour mieux reprendre demain
c'est un objectif à la fois sociales
éviter les vagues massives de
licenciement et économique car les
entreprises auront besoin de toutes
leurs compétences pour repartir après la
crise
l'arsenal de protection que nous
déployons pour protéger ses entreprises
repose sur six mesures
la première c'est la refonte complète du
système d'indemnisation au chômage
partiel le haut le vrai nom je redis
qu'est activité partielle et je redis
c'est très important pour les salariés
et pour les entreprises
quand on est en chômage partiel en
activité partielle on n'est pas au
chômage
on est en suspension de contrat de
travail et on est rémunéré à hauteur du
smic ou de 95 % de son salaire net si on
a un salaire supérieur mais on ne va pas
au chômage
il n'y a pas de démarche à faire et on
retrouve instantanément son contrat dès
que la période est terminée
l'élément nouveau et qui fait de ce
système le plus protecteur d'europe
c'est que nous avons décidé ce sera
l'objet d'un décret qui sera publié
demain que les entreprises seront
remboursés de l'intégralité de ses 84 %
de ce smic jusqu'à hauteur de quatre
fois et demi le suis
c'est à dire que pour toutes les petites
et moyennes entreprises l'intégralité
des salaires versés en chômage partiel
qui vont être remboursés et pour les
grandes entreprises
une très grande majorité la deuxième
mesure que nous avons pris c'est la
simplicité et la clarté du démarche du
chômage partiel
nous n'avons jamais fait un tel face à
un tel afflux de demandes
et pour cela il faut que les entreprises
les salariés aient confiance et qu'il
n'y ait pas de pression sur les délais
c'est pour ça que nous avons décidé que
les entreprises avaient 30 jours pour
déposer leurs demandes mais avec effet
rétroactif par la prise en compte du
chômage partiel dès le premier jour de
leur demande
d'autre part nous allons nous acceptons
désormais que le délai de réponse soit
de 48 heures
si au bout de 48 heures une entreprise
n'a pas de réponse ça veut dire que son
dossier est accepté et ne par ailleurs
nous avons donné une transparence sur
les instructions données au direct mes
services en région pour que tout ça se
fasse dans la transparence la plus
complète à la date de dernier comptage
il ya 24 heures il y avait déjà trente
sept mille entreprises qui ont demandé
le bénéfice du chômage partiel pour
leurs salariés
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir que
la moitié au moins de 10 salariés
je le rappelle l'entreprise même si vous
avez un seul salarié vous avez droit à
utiliser le chômage partiel
et si vous avez un apprenti aussi ils
sont couverts en ce qui concerne le
nombre de salariés couverts il ya déjà
sept cent soixante mille salariés qui
sont potentiellement couverts par le
chômage partiel
au vu des demandes des entreprises
évidemment nous en attendons plus nous
le savons et nous ferons tout pour
éviter les licenciements
préserver les compétences et donc ce
dispositif est un dispositif majeur dans
notre réponse économique et social la
troisième mesure concerne
l'intéressement participation évidemment
nous maintenons intégralement les droits
des salariés qui ont été acquis au titre
de 2010 9 mai nous donnons la
possibilité aux entreprises qui
rencontrent des difficultés de
trésorerie de verser ces sommes
jusqu'au 31 décembre et non pas d'ici le
30 juin
la quatrième mesure concerne les
souplesses données sur les congés
les rtt et congés liés aux comptes et en
épargne temps la première chose que je
dois le dire parce que beaucoup de gens
ne le savent pas en termes de congés
payés c'est qu'un employeur dans le code
du travail en dehors de la période
extraordinaire que nous vivons a déjà le
droit de fixer lui même les dates de
congés de ses salariés à condition
d'avoir un délai de prévenance de 1 mois
évidemment dans des entreprises en
difficulté
ce délai de prévenance d'un mois n'est
pas possible nous permettons donc qu'un
accord collectif un accord avec les
syndicats ou les salariés s'il n'y a pas
de syndicat au niveau de la branche de
l'entreprise puisse permettre de fixer
une semaine de congés pour tout le monde
au même moment dans les semaines qui
viennent
nous donnons également la possibilité à
l'employeur exceptionnellement de fixer
lui-même les dates jusqu'à 10 jours de
rtt ou compte épargne temps donc on le
change
aucun droit des salariés il n'y a pas un
seul jour de congé qui est supprimé mais
nous donnons par anticipation la
capacité avec accor à l'employeur de
fixer ces dates de congés pour jusqu'à
une semaine dans les semaines qui
viennent
la cinquième mesure concerne le droit du
travail sur les sujets de durée du
travail de ré peu repos hebdomadaire et
de repos dominical
là nous ne parlons pas des entreprises
en difficulté et en baisse d'activité
nous parlons au contraire des quelques
entreprises qui sont cruciales dans
cette période et qui ont font l'objet
d'un surcroît de demande
je pense notamment la fabrication des
masques des médicaments dans
l'agroalimentaire dans l'agriculture
dans l'énergie ces entreprises ont le
problème inverse des autres
elles ont besoin de plus de monde parce
qu'une partie des personnes peuvent être
malades ou confinés où par en gardant un
enfant et donc de façon temporaire pour
ces entreprises qui ont un surcroît
d'activité et qui dont le rôle est
crucial nous permettant de déroger aux
règles relatives à la durée du travail
au repos hebdomadaire et au dominical
pour les quelques semaines qui viennent
par exemple le travail du dimanche sera
ouvert dans ces entreprises
évidemment sur la base du
en ontario on pourra également travaillé
40 isern au +44 en moyenne sur 12
semaines voire de façon exceptionnelle
jusqu'à travailler jusqu'à 60 heures par
semaine en respectant naturellement les
temps de repos et en majorant les heures
supplémentaires dès la 36e heure de
travail
la liste de ces secteurs qui auront
cette dérogation temporaire sera publiée
par décret 6e mesure concerne
l'extension du bénéfice du chômage
partiel à des entreprises qui en sont
aujourd'hui exclues je pense notamment à
la ratp ou sncf et dont les conditions
financières seront définies entre les
ministères mais qui permettront aussi de
soutenir ses entreprises
la deuxième grande catégorie de mesure a
pour but de permettre aux salariés de
conserver leur emploi
je les dis nous voulons au maximum
éviter les licenciements
et donc pour cela prendre en charge
l'indemnisation des salariés en chômage
partiel je les dis 100% au speed 84 % du
salaire net au dessus
et pour cela nous voulons élargir à tous
les salariés
nous l'avons dit nous leur devons de
nous voulons laisser personne de côté
personne sur le bord du chemin personnes
sont un filet de sécurité
or aujourd'hui il ya une partie des
salariés qui n'ont pas le droit au
chômage partiel c'est ce que nous
changerons dans une ordonnance qui sera
publié dans les jours qui viennent
premièrement nous ouvrirons le bénéfice
du chômage partiel à ceux qui sont
exclus
aujourd'hui les assistantes maternelles
les employés à domicile les salariés au
forfait jours et au vert et les vrp
deuxièmement nous devons à tous les
salariés rémunérés en dessous du smic
une indemnité une indemnisation égale à
100% de leur salaire
cela concerne beaucoup de salariés qui
sont à temps partiel ainsi qu'une grande
majorité d'apprentis
troisièmement nous ouvrirons le bénéfice
du chômage partiel aux salariés qui sont
employées en france par une entreprise
qui paye ses cotisations mais qui n'a
pas d'établissements en france
enfin la quatrième mesure que nous
présentons pour protéger les salariés
c'est de renforcer la protection des
parents qui doivent garder leurs enfants
vous le savez nous avons nous mettons en
place un système d'indemnités
journalières
optionnel parce que ses parents ne sont
pas malades et il bénéficie d'un arrêt
de travail indemniser comme s'il était
malade il n'y aura ni des carences nique
une condition d'ancienneté l'ordonance
prévoir que leur rémunération sera au
moins égal à 90% de leur salaire net
notre troisième série de mesures
concerne la protection du niveau de vie
de ceux des chômeurs évidemment parmi
les demandeurs d'emploi certains
arrivent en fin de droits sont dans des
situations précaires et dans cette
situation où évidemment retrouver un
emploi est quasiment impossible pour la
plupart nous voulons les protéger de
cette risque de niveau de vie qui
pourrait baisser rapidement
nous prenons donc cinq séries de mesures
pour protéger les chômeurs premièrement
pour tous les chômeurs en fin de droits
nous prolongeons les droits au mois
d'avril sur la base de l'indemnisation
du mois de mars alors que normalement
leur droits étant épuisé il n'aurait
plus eu droit à l'assurance-chômage et
nous le ferons
tant que dure la période de crise
sanitaire
deuxièmement pour les intermittents du
spectacle pour tout ce qui arrivait en
fin de droit et qui évidemment ne
peuvent plus exercer leur métier
puisqu'il n'y a plus aucun spectacle aux
événements qui peut se tenir
nous reportons cette fin de droits
jusqu'à la fin de la période de crise
sanitaire
pour tous la période de confinement des
droits sera de confinement l'état dans
tous pendant la période de confinement
les droits seront neutralisées dans le
calcul des droits c'est les fameuses 507
heures nécessaires sur les deux jours
troisièmement pour les intérimaires
il bénit ce fear is bénéficieront
automatiquement du chômage partiel dans
tous les cas jusqu'à la fin de leur
mission qu'elle soit exercée ou pas pour
les saisonniers
nous leur apportons le bénéfice
automatique du chômage partiel au moins
jusqu au 15 avril et au delà si leur
durée de contrat le prévoit y est même
s'ils n'ont plus de travail je pense
notamment aux stations de ski dont les
qui sont toutes fermées depuis plusieurs
semaines enfin pour tous les chômeurs la
période de confinement sera neutralisée
dans les calculs des droits nous ferons
dans les calculs de droit comme si cette
période n'avait pas existé on ne pas
pénaliser les chômeurs ou
au moment où l'activité reprendra vous
le voyez notre détermination est totale
pour répondre aux besoins de tous et
apporter un filet de sécurité
entreprises petites ou grandes salariés
apprentis salariés à temps partiel
chômeurs intérimaire intermittents
saisonniers nous mettons tout en oeuvre
pour les protéger des conséquences
économiques et sociales de la crise quoi
qu'il arrive et permettent tous ensemble
dans une france solidaire et au pays lui
repartir ensuite plus vite et unis ce
que je vous propose pour permettre aux
ministres ensuite de pouvoir honorer le
reste de leur rendez vous c'est de
thématiser des questions si vous en êtes
d'accord
je propose qu'on commence par les
questions justice ou en tout cas il y en
a pas et bas très bas donc je peux
libérer tout de suite madame la garde
des sceaux
je vous remercie madame la garde des
sceaux et donc je vous propose qu'on
fasse les questions économiques qui
s'adresse à monsieur le maire représente
aujourd'hui tous mes collègues et
confrères
monsieur le maire est ce que vous avez
une idée plus précise de la récession
économique qui attend la france cette
année vous avez fait l'hypothèse d'un
pour cent de récession est ce que vous
avez aujourd'hui une estimation après
plus précise sur le croissance est elle
aussi peut-être sur le taux de chômage
enfin j'ai déjà indiqué que je ne leur
donnerai pas de prévisions de croissance
et un chiffre qui est inscrit au projet
de loi de finances rectificative - 1 %
pour 2020
ce chiffre sera beaucoup plus
significatif nous savons tous et nous
avons des indications précises notamment
avec le fameux indice qui m a été sorti
hier qui montrent que nous sommes très
en dessous des 50 points au dessus de 50
nous sommes en période de croissance en
dessous de 50
nous sommes en période de récession et
cet indice pour la zone euro est tout
juste au dessus de 30
même chose pour la france cet indice
nous indique également qu' il ya de
fortes disparités entre l'industrie qui
est encore un peu au dessus de 40
et les services qui eux sont autour de
tout ça signifie un recul très marqué de
l'activité économique en 2020 et ce sera
j'ai déjà indiqué très au delà des -1%
mais je pense qu'il ne sert à rien de se
livrer à un exercice consistant à
modifier semaine après semaine mois
après mois la perspective de croissance
pour la france
lorsqu'il y aura un nouveau projet de
loi de finances rectificative il sera
bien temps de faire une nouvelle
prévision pour 2020 et je pense que mes
propos sont suffisamment claires
j'ajoute que ce chiffre dépendra
évidemment de la durée de confinement la
priorité c'est la sécurité sanitaire
donc nous garantissons la sécurité
sanitaire par le confinement qui a été
décidé par le présent avis public par le
premier ministre et il ya évidemment un
impact direct de la durée confinement
sur la croissance
l'impact également de cette crise
sanitaire sur un nos partenaires
commerciaux majeurs qui et les états
unis sera décisive pour le choc sur la
croissance française en 2011 vous voyez
quelques indications que je peux vous
donner aussi je ne livrerai pas un
exercice sur le niveau du chômage
aujourd'hui l'heure est d'abord à la
mobilisation de tous les instruments
pour faire face à ce choc très brutal
sur la croissance française lui d'autres
questions pour vous monsieur le maire
est ce que le gouvernement français
favorables à la mise en place de ce
qu'on appelle le maintenant les corona
band le présent la république a déjà
indiqué que la france était favorable à
ce type de dispositif je voudrais
simplement rappeler que l'union
européenne des importuns certain nombre
de réponses et je tiens à saluer les
réponses ont été apportées déjà dans le
domaine économique et financier par
l'union européenne et d'abord eu le
déclenchement de cette clause par la
présidente de la commission européenne
qui nous permet de nous dégager
toutes les règles du pacte de stabilité
et de croissance
c'est une décision qui est forte qui
donne à tous les états la liberté
nécessaire pour engager les dépenses
publiques dont nous avons besoin pour
soutenir les salariés et soutenir les
entreprises il ya une deuxième décision
qui a été prise c'est de nous permettre
d'apporter des aides d'état aux
entreprises qui en auraient besoin
ces décisions que tout est annoncé par
la commissaire européenne margrethe
vestager comme je lé déjà indiqué
beaucoup d'entreprises notamment dans le
secteur industriel auront besoin du
soutien de l'état
il est très important que nous ne soyons
pas contraint par les règles des aides
d'état
enfin je rappelle que la banque centrale
européenne a mis sur le marché
750 milliards d'euros c'est une bonne
décision
une décision forte il va de soi pour
nous que la banque centrale européenne
doit être au premier rang des réponses
qui sont apportées aujourd'hui à la
crise économique qui touche tous les
pays de la zone euro elle doit être au
premier rang nous avons hier lors de la
réunion des ministres des finances de la
zone euro commencé à étudier des
dispositifs complémentaires je pense en
particulier au mécanisme européen de
stabilité
nous sommes favorables au recours au
mécanisme européen de stabilité il était
prévu pour ça pour faire face à des
situations de crise exceptionnelle nous
sommes dans une situation de crise
exceptionnelle il nous paraît donc
légitime de recourir au mécanisme
européen de stabilité ces indications
qui ont été retenus par les états
membres de la zone euro et qui
figureront dans le courrier que le
président de l'eurogroupe maillot cente
nos adressé aux chefs d'état en vue du
conseil européen de demain
enfin il ya la troisième série de
réponses
3e série de réponses et la réflexion sur
ces fameux 'eurobonds' ou core la bombe
quel que soit le nom qu'on lui apporte
nous nous estimons que ce serait un
témoignage de la solidarité économique
et financière entre les états membres de
l'ue
non et s'il ya bien une chose dans la
zone euro a besoin aujourd'hui c'est de
solidarité c'est de comprendre les dix
neuf états membres de la zone euro sont
liés les uns aux autres par une monnaie
commune et par un destin économique
commun donc nous devons tous nous sentir
liés par ce qui arrive à tous les pays
de la zone euro
le chacun pour soi entraînera la
disparition de la zone euro la
solidarité qui peut se manifester par
exemple parler corona bombes ou des
'eurobonds' renforcera la zone euro et
renforcera l'une des plus grandes
conquêtes politiques de l'union
européenne c'est-à-dire la monnaie
unique
vous avez évoqué des secteurs attaqués
sur les marchés financiers ce que vous
pouvez plus précis sur la question est
qu'est ce que peut faire le gouvernement
français comme ça ça je peux pas vous
donner de noms d'entreprises mais chacun
voit bien que ces secteurs industriels
aujourd'hui qui est le plus touché
kylie a dans ce secteur industriel
notamment l'industrie automobile il y a
également tout transport aérien ce sont
des secteurs qui sont très violemment
touchée par la crise économique
nous avons plusieurs instruments notre
disposition la montée au capital
la recapitalisation les nationalisations
nous avons tous ces instruments et nous
sommes prêts à utiliser l'ensemble de
ces instruments qui sont à la
disposition de la puissance publique
merci j'ai une question maintenant pour
madame pénicaud merci
une question de michel rose de l' agence
reuters
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que
certains grands groupes profite d'un
effet d'aubaine en recourant massivement
au chômage partiel
il évoque notamment le cas de sfr qui se
lancent les syndicats pour aimer de 60%
de ses salariés en chômage partiel
est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas des
conditions plus drastiques pour le
recours au chômage partiel pour les
grands groupes
merci alors le choix que nous avons fait
vous l'avez compris c'est d'éviter les
vagues de licenciements
je rappelle qu'en 2009 on a mis des
années et des années à récupérer la même
mis dix ans à retrouver le niveau
d'emploi et de chômage de 2009 donc
notre choix et le président de la
république l'a affirmé avec force dans
son allocution
c'est de mettre tous les moyens sur le
chômage partiel qui évite ces vagues de
licenciements alors on est dans un
processus de confiance a priori c'est
important pour que ça aille vite
je le disais la moitié les entreprises
qui sollicitent chômage partiel c'est
des toutes petites entreprises
si les délais d'instruction sont trop
longs elles vont se retrouver en
défaillance de paix mais des paiements
pour payer les salaires de leurs
salariés
nous faisons le choix de la confiance
mais la confiance n'exclut pas le
contrôle a posteriori et notamment pour
les grandes entreprises nous avons quand
même un oeil très attentif
je pense qu'en termes de solidarité
nationale une grande entreprise si elle
n'a pas de difficultés majeures
d'activité doit en tenir compte et on
examinera au cas par cas et dossier ça
dépend beaucoup du type d'activité
évidemment par exemple air france pour
prendre un exemple est profondément
touché et là on a évidemment accepté un
dossier très important chômage partiel
pour sauver les emplois et sauvé d'une
certaine façon l'entreprise mais nous
aurons un examen au cas par cas si
l'activité peut continuer si le
télétravail est pas utilisé et bien il
n'y a pas de raison qui est du chômage
partiel on utilise d'abord le
télétravail on continue l'activité est
une entreprise si ensuite objectivement
ne peut pas poursuivre son activité
alors le chômage partiel est ouvert
aussi votre entreprise que c'est toutes
tailles d'entreprises tous secteurs
mais bien sûr il ya un examen au cas par
cas plus vigilants et plus a priori
dans les grandes entreprises que dans
les petites questions
une question beaucoup de journalistes se
pose le conseil scientifique qui hier a
évoqué une période de confinement de six
semaines
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
aujourd'hui c'est du gouvernement va
suivre cet avis et quand est-ce qu'on en
saura un peu plus sur le prolongement de
ce confinement
merci comme vous le savez la france est
entrée dans cette stratégie du
confinement depuis mercredi dernier à 12
heures pour une période d'au minimum
quinze jours c'était ce qu'avait indiqué
le président de la république dont on ne
sommes pas au bout de cette première
période de confinement nous avions
toujours indiqué que nous serions
attentifs aux recommandations du comité
scientifique qui nous permettra
d'éclairer la décision politique qui
sera la nôtre nous avons entre
guillemets pris acte de la proposition
qui nous étaient faites de la
recommandation de fort qui nous était
fait d'avoir un confinement d'au moins
six semaines qui leur paraît être une
durée minimale si je comprends bien la
vie qui a été prononcée comme le
ministre de la santé a eu l'occasion de
le dire
nous considérons que le confinement
devra durer le temps que qui sera
nécessaire et donc nous annoncerons dans
les prochains jours la manière dont nous
entendons mettre en oeuvre les
recommandations du conseil scientifique
merci j'ai une question de laurence
benhamou de la lfp concernant la
situation dans les ehpad est ce que on a
une idée du nombre de décès au niveau
national dans les ehpad et est ce que le
gouvernement compte communiquer plus
régulièrement sur ce sujet dans les
prochains jours alors je voudrais
d'abord parce que j'entends
au-delà de la question qui est posée par
votre collègue le fait que nous serions
dans une stratégie de dissimulation
vis-à-vis du nombre de personnes
décédées on n'est pas ils ont évidemment
rien je voudrais d'abord rappeler le
fait que le directeur général de la
santé lorsque régulièrement en général
une fois par jour et donne
nombre de chiffres en particulier ceux
liés au décès il s'agit de remonter
direct et automatique nous provenant des
différents hôpitaux de france qui
accueille des patients malades du coït
pour ce qui est des ehpad ce type de
remontée là n'existait pas c'est à l'ab
le mans à la crise
il est en train d'être mises en place
actuellement et donc de manière très
rapide
nous aurons une remontée en temps réel
du nombre de décès dans les ehpad ce qui
nous permettra par comparaison avec
notamment le nombre de décès habituel à
la même époque dans ces établissements
de voir s'il ya une surmortalité il va
sans dire que compte tenu des premières
informations j'allais dire informel dont
nous disposons il y a effectivement des
établissements qui aujourd'hui font face
à une surmortalité
mais nous mettons en place le dispositif
pour que en toute transparence on puisse
apporter des réponses à des questions
que se posent légitimement nos
concitoyens d'autre part et de manière
générale sur la question des données
nous travaillons actuellement avec le
service d'information du gouvernement
pour faire en sorte de rendre publiques
les données qui sont à notre disposition
notamment sur des cartes interactives
qui permettront d'avoir une idée assez
précise de combien de personnes ont été
détectés positifs bukovine 19 par les
tests de pcr du nombre de personnes qui
sont hospitalisées du nombre de
personnes qui sont en réanimation etc
etc qui permettra d'apporter avec toute
la transparence qui est requis dans la
gestion de cette crise
des réponses aux questions que nos
concitoyens se pose merci j'ai une
question de d'alison tassin de tf1 lci
que je vous pose est ce que l'état de
s'en priver les clinics sont intégrés un
mot disant grand est où la situation est
très tendue
est-ce que la mise en place de cet
hôpital militaire que monsieur macro ont
investi cet après midi ne répond pas
justement un manque dans ce domaine là
alors d'abord il faut bien comprendre
que la stratégie que nous avons eues
consistant à des programmes et des
opérations pour pouvoir libérer des lits
de réanimation et dé lui
de manière générale de soins et critique
elle c'est évidemment appuyé aussi bien
sûr le public que sur le privé parce qu
il va sans dire que nous n'entendons pas
en aucune manière nous priver de
possibilité d'avoir des lits dès lors
que les hôpitaux privés sont disponibles
donc ils sont évidemment sollicités dans
cette stratégie nationale d'augmentation
de nos capacités réanimatoires ça c'est
la première chose
la deuxième chose nous donnons des
instructions au samu smur de manière à
pouvoir orienter les patients qui ne
relève pas forcément encore du coït 19
en direction quand il appelle les
urgences en direction de
l'hospitalisation privée ce qui permet
de soulager l'hôpital public
je voudrais également souligner que les
hôpitaux privés ont été sollicités pour
pouvoir faire des prêts de matériel en
particulier de respirateurs aux hôpitaux
publics qui absorbe entre guillemets la
première vague mais dès lors que nous
sommes dans des situations de saturation
il va sans dire que les hôpitaux privés
sont très largement sollicités aussi en
fonction de la nature des lits de
réanimation dont ils disposent puisque
il ya différents types de lits de
réanimation et dont tous ne sont pas
adaptés au traitement des patients
qu'aux vide en fonction de si vous avez
des respirateurs lourds ou légers
la dernière chose que je voudrais
ajouter c'est que bien entendu dès lors
qu'il ya de la déprogrammation date dans
les hôpitaux privés
il y a donc du personnel médical qui est
disponible et ce personnel médical
évidemment est sollicité en tant que de
besoin dans les hôpitaux publics
sur un autre sujet une question que se
posent beaucoup journalistes est ce que
le cracking
des français d'aidés patio est il
envisagé à ce stade en france est-ce
qu'il a été mise à l'étude
et dans le même dans le même ordre
d'idée ce matin le défenseur des droits
jacques toubon a demandé un débat public
sur les libertés est ce que le
gouvernement souhaite que ce débat se
tienne alors il est évidemment légitime
s'agissant de questions de cette nature
qu' il y ait un débat public politique
dans la société française parce que ce
sont évidemment des éléments dès lors
qu'on touche à la protection des données
personnelles auxquelles vous le savez ce
gouvernement est particulièrement
attaché nous avons effectivement
aujourd'hui en cours des contacts pour
comprendre de quoi on parle
parce que entre eux ce qui a été mis en
place dans des pays asiatiques à
singapour en corée du sud ce qu'est ce
qui est en cours de réflexion
manifestement dans un certain nombre de
pays européens
il s'agit de comprendre très précisément
de quoi on nous parle également de
vérifier l'intérêt sanitaire que ça peut
avoir contenu de l'ensemble de la
stratégie que nous mettons en oeuvre en
particulier de la stratégie visant à
organiser la fin du confinement donc de
ce fait nous n'avons aujourd'hui aucune
initiative gouvernementale plus avancé
que ce que je vous dis cette recherche
d'informations à l'échelle
internationale qui n'ait été prise par
le gouvernement
ce matin également le martin hirsch a
appelé une réquisition des soignants
pour faire face à la vague qui qui est
en train d'arriver en ile de france
est-ce que c'est envisagé est ce qu'ils
demandent par ailleurs le versement de
primes pour les soignants à ce que ça
aussi s'envisager
la situation en ile de france est une
situation dans laquelle nous sommes pas
encore à saturation du système puisque
tous les lits 2
animations ne sont pas occupés mais
compte tenu de l'évolution épidémique
c'est une situation que nous regardons
évidemment avec énormément d'attention
la stratégie nationale que nous avons
eue est une stratégie de démodé de
déprogrammation à la fois dans le public
est à la fois dans le privé qui nous
permet de libérer des lits de
réanimation et donc c'est une stratégie
que nous poursuivons nous faisons
également appel à la bonne volonté de
soignants qui pour diverses raisons ne
sont pas des soignants aujourd'hui en
poste c'est le sujet de la réserve
sanitaire et cela a permis en ile de
france notamment pour la ph v d'avoir un
renfort d'un millier de personnels
soignants dans différentes disciplines
médicales et paramédicales qui vont
venir d'ores et déjà renforcé
l'ap-hp nous sommes également en
capacité de toujours
enfin nous essayons toujours d'augmenter
cette capacité en lits hospitaliers et
donc nous déployons cette stratégie
sanitaire en ile de france qui est en ce
moment en train d'être de plus en plus
sollicités contenu de la courbe
épidémique mais comme nous le faisons
partout ailleurs dans les départements
où dans les régions qui ont un ou deux
ans sur un autre sujet le ministre de la
culture hier didier guillaume appelé ce
qui n'avait plus d'activité à aller
aider les agriculteurs et scapa là
encore un message contradictoire entre
dire aux gens qu'il faut rester chez eux
se confiner et leur dire mais si vous ne
faites rien vous valez les agriculteurs
qui sont aider les agriculteurs pendant
qu'ils sont en manque de main d'oeuvre
alors je voudrais apporter une double
réponse peut être une réponse générale
qui sur ce qui pourrait apparaître comme
une injonction entre guillemets
paradoxale entre le fait que nous avons
besoin pour pouvoir casser les chaînes
de contamination réduire le nombre de
contacts sociaux que les français
restent chez eux et dans le même temps
ce qui peut paraître paradoxal le fait
que nous ayons besoin aussi que des gens
travaillent
je voudrais prendre au fond peut-être
une image qui permettra de rendre compte
de la situation dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation de guerre sanitaire dans cette
guerre sanitaires on a des bataillons
différents et chacun a un rôle important
pour pouvoir gagner cette guerre il y a
ceux qui sur la ligne de front
et je pense en l'occurrence aux
soignants vont avoir besoin de
travailler évidemment puisque c'est eux
qui vont pouvoir sauver des vies au
quotidien accueillir des patients au
quotidien ces soignants ils ont besoin
de matériel dans les hôpitaux
évidemment de matériel de protection
mais également de différents matériels
des fluides de l'oxygène des médicaments
à l'intérieur des hôpitaux ces soignants
ils ont besoin de se transporter depuis
leur lieu de résidence vers leur lieu de
travail
ces soignants ils ont évidemment besoin
de vivre dans des appartements qui sont
alimentés en eau en électricité
les hôpitaux ont besoin de
télécommunications ça fait référence par
exemple à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur la remontée automatique
d'informations au niveau national
concernant le nombre d'admissions le
nombre de décès et c est donc cette
première ligne de front a besoin pour
fonctionner qu'un certain nombre de
personnes dans un autre bataillon en
quelque sorte travail au quotidien
il se tut doivent travailler au
quotidien parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'abord
parce que c'est nécessaire pour que
l'activité de front puissent être
remplies ces personnes évidemment
doivent pouvoir travailler avec des
mesures et des précautions sanitaires
qui répondent à la demande de
distanciation de ce fameux maître de
protection entre les individus c'est au
fond de bras qu'on met entre soi et la
personne d'à côté et donc il faut
éventuellement pas éventuellement mais
il faut réorganiser les chaînes de
production pour que cela soit possible
il y à aussi est scellée au fond le 3ème
bataillon ceux qui parce qu'ils restent
chez eux pouvant le télétravail et où
devant garder leurs enfants participant
fait à la bataille et c'est vrai que
c'est assez difficile d'imaginer que
parce qu'on fait rien et qu'on est à la
maison au conte télétravail bah en fait
on participe activement à la bataille
parce que ce qui nous permettra de
remporter la bataille contre le
coronavirus c'est une chose principale
la diminution des contacts entre les
individus et donc au fond on a loi on a
là trois groupements la population ceux
qui sont sur le front sanitaire ce sont
les soignants ceux qui par leurs
activités professionnelles permettent
d'organiser la vie
du pays et la continuité de la vie du
pays et ceux qui parce qu'ils restent
chez eux casse les chaînes de
contamination et donc permettre de
ralentir la propagation de l'épidémie
pour revenir plus particulièrement sur
les propos du ministre de l'agriculture
il s'illustre parfaitement dans la
bataille que nous menons avec ses
différents bataillon parce que oui
actuellement il y à des récoltes je
pense en particulier aux fraises et aux
asperges qui doivent être effectués
compte tenu de la fermeture des
frontières on a un nombre très réduit de
travailleurs qui habituellement venant
de l'étranger en particulier l'union
européenne de remplissait ses activités
là dans les champs et qui aujourd'hui ne
sont plus disponibles de fait et donc
l'appel du ministre de l'agriculture
avait vocation à dire que là où c'était
possible sans traverser évidemment toute
la france puisque de toute façon c'est
pas possible compte tenu de la réduction
de l'offre de trains que les gens qui
pouvaient le faire avait vocation à
aller donner un coup de main évidemment
rémunérée là c'était possible et dans
les régions où il ya des récoltes
actuellement il va sans dire que nous
n'entendons pas demander un enseignant
qui aujourd'hui ne travaille pas compte
tenu de la fermeture des écoles de
traverser la france entière pour aller
récolter des fraises gariguettes merci
j'ai une question de arthur berda du
figaro
le président république valait cet
après-midi à mulhouse ont visité l'hôtel
le plus tard dans un hôpital militaire
quel message veut il faire passer en
allant beaucoup sur le terrain comme il
le fait depuis
depuis une quinzaine de jours et
pourquoi ne prend t'il pas toujours la
précaution de mettre un masque alors
croisons quand on voit le président
poutine en russie qui lui fait des
déplacements avec une combinaison est
bien d'abord il ya une double occasion
dans ce que vous dites
il était important pour le président la
république d'être évidemment aux côtés
aux côtés pardon des français que ce
soit ceux qui sont dans la première
ligne sanitaire que ce soit ceux qui
viennent en renfort je pense en
particulier au service de santé des
armées qui déploie actuellement le
module dont vous parlez et qui participe
à travers leurs actes leurs actions à
l'accompagnement des soignants que ce
soit dans les établissements
médico-sociaux je pense aux déplacements
qu'il a eu l'occasion de faire auprès
d'un établissement qui accueille des
personnes sans domicile fixe et donc il
aura vocation
quand il le jugera nécessaire n'étant
pas sa conseillère je ne peux pas
évidemment le deviner à l'avance d'être
auprès des français est de ceux qui par
leurs différentes actions leurs
différentes activités concourent à cette
guerre sanitaires pourquoi est ce que le
président de la république n'est pas
muni d'un masque mais tout simplement
parce qu'il n'ya pas besoin d'un masque
dès lors qu'on respecte la distance de
protection vis-à-vis des autres et donc
vous avez vu au cours de ce compte rendu
du conseil des ministres que nous étions
nous ministre avec le premier ministre à
une distance de un mètres les uns des
autres de manière à avoir cette
protection naturelle vis-à-vis des
postillons quand on parle de la toux et
des éternuements
c'est le même processus que nous mettons
en place pour les conseils des ministres
où on a un nombre restreint de personnes
autour du président la république
toujours distante de ce maître de
protection et donc dès lors que la
recommandation sanitaire qui est fait
est que le port du masque en population
générale
lorsque nous ne sommes pas malade ou
lorsque nous ne sommes pas soignant
n'est pas utile il n'y a pas de raison
que le président de la république déroge
aux prescriptions qui sont réalisés pour
l'ensemble de la population française
avec d'europe 1 est ce que vous savez
quand est ce que les autres ordonnances
seront adoptées en conseil des ministres
alors je n'ai pas encore la date d'un du
prochain conseil des ministres peut-être
avant la semaine prochaine peut être
uniquement la semaine prochaine
aujourd'hui les administrations
travaille vraiment d'arrache-pied pour
rédiger de manière correcte et sans que
cela puisse souffrir d'aucune erreur les
différentes habilitations et donc le
travail est en cours je ne peux pas vous
apporter de réponse à ce stade et enfin
une dernière question est ce qu'on a une
idée un peu plus précise sur la sur
l'échéance pour la généralisation des
tests
alors vous le savez comme l'a indiqué
hier le directeur général de la santé le
professeur salomon nous avons
aujourd'hui une montée en puissance du
nombre de tests que nous pouvons
réaliser
nous sommes quasiment nous étions à 5000
nous sommes en train de monter vers dix
mille on pourra passer les 20000 dans
quelques semaines tests réalisés par
jour son temps on parle bien de ce qu'on
appelle les tests pcr qui sont des tests
qui vont rechercher la présence du virus
dans votre sang au moment où vous
démarrez la maladie et donc c'est des
tests j'allais dire qu'ils sont avant
nous avons nous sommes également en
train de développer ça c'est de la
recherche scientifique et médicale des
types de tests qui vont nous permettre
en fait d'être plus rapide ou ce qu'on
appelle les autotests et enfin on a une
troisième série de tests qu'on utilise
qui sont ce qu'on appelle les tests
sérologiques et qui permettent en fait a
posteriori de savoir si vous avez été
immunisés je voudrais rappeler quand
même que la recommandation qui était
celle du centre de contrôle européen et
de l' oms était dans un premier temps
d'avoir des tests dans les stades
1 et 2 d'une épidémie d'avoir des tests
qui permettent de remonter les chaînes
de contamination est donc de
circonscrire au fond la propagation du
virus
la recommandation de l' oms a évolué
puisque elle recommande de tester tester
tester
selon les
recommandations et le discours qu'a tenu
le directeur général de l'om est ce
c'est une recommandation qui est assez
récente que nous avons évidemment pris
en compte ce qui conduit à cette
augmentation de capacité à réaliser des
tests et qui nous conduit également à
travailler sur une doctrine pour la
réalisation de tests de manière encore
plus importante à la soeur au moment où
nous sortirons du confinement très bien
je vous remercie a très vite